WE ARE GOING TO COVER ALL OF
THAT AND SO MUCH MORE AN
IMPORTANT BREAKING NEWS HOUR
COMING UP ON HANNITY.
♪ ALL RIGHT.
SOME MAJOR NEW DEVELOPMENTS.
NEW INFORMATION TONIGHT
BECAUSE OF A MOUNTAIN OF
IRREFUTABLE EVIDENCE.
PRESSURE IS BUILDING AT THIS
HOUR FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF THE UNITED
STATES, JEFF SESSIONS, TO
NOW APPOINT A SECOND SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
NOW, SENATORS CHUCK
GRASSLEY, LINDSEY GRAHAM,
ALONG WITH SENATORS JOHN
CORNYN, THOM TILLIS, THEY
ARE NOW JOINING THE CHORUS
THAT ARE DEMANDING THAT
SESSIONS NOW FINALLY TAKE
ACTION SO REAL CRIMES THAT
WE KNOW WERE COMMIT CAN NOW
BE INVESTIGATED.
TAKING A LOOK.
>> THE FBI AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WERE
CORRUPT IN MY VIEW WHEN IT
CAME TO HANDLING THE EMAIL
INVESTIGATION OF CLINTON AND
THE ENTIRE FISA WARRANT
APPLICATION PROCESS WAS
ABUSED.
>> CHANCES THAT YOU GET A
SPECIAL COUNSEL IN ADDITION
TO WHAT'S ALREADY THERE.
>> I WILL BE SHOCKED IF
SOMEBODY DOESN'T SEE THE
INHERENT CONFLICT IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
REGARDING INVESTIGATING
ITSELF.
HIGH PROBABILITY.
>> I'M GOING TO USE AS MUCH
LEVERAGE AS I CAN, AND I
THINK I HAVE A LOT TO GET
THE JOB DONE.
>> Sean: SOURCES TELLING US
TONIGHT THERE IS A VERY HIGH
PROBABILITY THAT SESSION
ALSO ACT AND HE WILL APPOINT
A SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL
THIS WILL BE A HUGE VICTORY
FOR ALL OF YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, IT IS WHY WE HAVE
BEEN CALLING FOR A SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSEL FOR OVER A
YEAR.
NOW, THIS INVESTIGATION IS
NOW REACHING A NEW LEVEL AND
WE'RE TOLD THERE WILL BE NEW
EXPLOSIVE DEVELOPMENTS
UNFOLDING IN COMING DAYS.
IN A LETTER TO THE A.G.,
JEFF SESSIONS AND DEPUTY
A.G. ROD ROSENSTEIN WHILE
SENATOR GRASSLEY AND GRAHAM
EXPLAIN EXACTLY WHY A SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSEL IS NEEDED.
THESE SCANDALS DIRECTLY
IMPLICATE KEY MEMBERS OF THE
FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
SO IT MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THOSE ORGANIZATIONS TO
INVESTIGATE THEMSELVES.
NOW, KEY SECTIONS OF THE
GRASSLEY-GRAHAM CRIMINAL
REFERRAL AGAINST THE FAKE
NEWS DOSSIER AUTHOR
CHRISTOPHER STEELE NOW
TONIGHT THEY ARE UNREDACTED
AND GRAHAM-CASSIDYLY AND
GRAHAM RIGHTLY ARE ASKING
THE DOJ TO INVESTIGATE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE FOR LYING
TO THE FBI ABOUT HIS
CONTACTS WITH THE MEDIA.
REMEMBER, STEELE WAS
SHOPPING THE FAKE NEWS
DOSSIER AROUND TO EVERYBODY
IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA, ALL
THESE OUTLETS LIKE THE "NEW
YORK TIMES," "THE WASHINGTON
POST," YAHOO NEWS, FAKE NEWS
CNN, OH, AND BY THE WAY,
STEELE IS A FOREIGN ACTOR IN
BED WITH PHONY RUSSIAN
SOURCES.
EVEN HE DIDN'T BELIEVE WHAT
HE PRINTED IN THE DOSSIER.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS SUPPOSED
CRIMINAL EVEN, THAT, IN
FACT, STEELE WOULD BE
WORKING AS A NON-FOREIGN
ACTOR WITH RUSSIANS TO
INFLUENCE AN AMERICAN
ELECTION.
DID HE EVER REGISTER WITH
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT?
NOW ALSO TONIGHT, BRAND NEW
NEWS.
FOX NEWS REPORTING DISGRACED
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW
MCCABE, THIS IS HUGE, IS NOW
BEGGING TOP DOJ OFFICIALS.
REMEMBER, IS HE A FORMER
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE FBI,
THAT HE NOT BE FIRED BECAUSE
STARTING SUNDAY HE WOULD
BEGIN TO GET HIS LUCRATIVE
GOVERNMENT PENSION.
HE IS SET TO RETIRE ON
SUNDAY.
BUT HE IS LIKELY GOING TO BE
FIRED TOMORROW.
NOW, THE FACT THAT MCCABE IS
EVEN THAT THE POINT IS SO
SIGNIFICANT AND IT MEANS
SOMETHING, WHAT, MCCABE DID
SOMETHING REALLY, REALLY
WRONG.
YOU DON'T GET FIRED OVER
NOTHING, ESPECIALLY BEING
THE DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR
WORKING AT THE BUREAU FOR
OVER 20 YEARS.
AND SOURCES ARE TELLING US
TONIGHT THAT MCCABE COULD
FACE MULTIPLE CRIMINAL
CHARGES.
REMEMBER, MCCABE, HE WAS PUT
ON LEAVE AFTER THE CURRENT
FBI DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER
WRAY, REMEMBER, HE FOUND OUT
WHAT WE'LL FIND OUT SOON,
WHAT IS BEING EXPOSED IN THE
UPCOMING INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
REPORT.
AND FOR THE IG REPORT, DON'T
THINK THAT WHAT MCCABE DID
HAPPENED IN A VACUUM.
REMEMBER, MCCABE DIDN'T DO
THIS ALONE.
THE IG REPORT IS SUPPOSED TO
COVER, LOOK AT THE LIST, THE
CORRUPT CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION, HILLARY
HAVING THAT UNSECURE SERVER
THAT WAS STORED IN THE MOM
AND POP SHOP BATHROOM CLOSET
WHERE SHE DELETED 33,000
SUBPOENAED EMAILS.
AND HER AIDES WERE SMASHING
DEVICES AND ACID WASHING AND
BLEACH BIT THE CLINTON LYNCH
TARMAC MEETING WITH BILL
CLINTON.
THEN I HAVE WHAT I CALL
EXONERATION BEFORE
INVESTIGATION.
YOU HAD COMEY AND STRZOK AND
PAGE AND OTHER TOP FBI
OFFICIALS THEY PUT THE FIX
IN.
THEY CONCLUDED THEIR
INVESTIGATION LONG BEFORE
THEY EVEN INTERVIEWED
HILLARY CLINTON AND 17 OTHER
KEY WITNESSES.
WHICH, BY THE WAY, GOES
AGAINST WHAT JAMES COMEY
SAID UNDER OATH WHEN HE
CLAIMED IN FRONT OF CONGRESS
HE DIDN'T REACH A CONCLUSION
ON THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION UNTIL AFTER
INTERVIEWING HILLARY.
BUT THAT'S NOT TRUE.
WE KNOW IT'S NOT TRUE.
SO YOU HAVE HILLARY.
SHE RIGGED HER PRIMARY.
SHE HAS HER FRIENDS AT THE
FBI.
THEN PUT THE FIX IN AS IT
RELATES TO CRIMES SHE
COMMITTED.
THEN SHE TRIES TO INFLUENCE
THE GENERAL ELECTION, PAYING
OVER $12 MILLION TO A GUY
OUTSIDE OF AMERICA FOR
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT LIES AND
PROPAGANDA ALL TO LIE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BY THE WAY, ROBERT MUELLER,
HOW ABOUT INVESTIGATING REAL
CRIMES TONIGHT?
AND BY THE WAY, SINCE WE
FOUND OUT THAT THOSE CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR LIES,
WHICH THE FBI, THEY NEVER
VERIFIED, THEY NEVER
CORROBORATED.
WELL THEN THEY TOOK THOSE
LIES TO THE FISA JUDGE AND
THEY USED THE LIES AND
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA TO GET A
WARRANT TO SPY ON A MEMBER
OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WELL THAT THEN, OF COURSE,
GAVE THEM ACCESS TO TRUMP
CAMPAIGN COMMUNICATIONS.
NOW, REMEMBER, THE FBI'S OWN
PROTOCOLS AND FISA LAWS, IT
SAYS THAT INFORMATION NEEDS
TO BE VERIFIED AND
CORROBORATED INDEPENDENTLY
BEFORE IT EVER GOES TO A
FISA COURT JUDGE.
THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
AND IT DIDN'T HAPPEN ONCE.
FISA JUDGES WERE LIED TO ON
FOUR SEPARATE OCCASIONS.
THIS IS BEYOND A MASSIVE
SCANDAL.
AND I KNOW THE MEDIA IS
IGNORANT, LAZY AND OVERPAID.
IT'S WHY JEFF SESSIONS IS
NOW LOOKING TO THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL AND NOW LOOKING INTO
THE SEVERE FISA ABUSES BUT,
REMEMBER, HERE'S THE
PROBLEM.
THE IG, INSPECTOR GENERAL
HOROWITZ, HE HAS NO
PROSECUTORIAL POWERS, HENCE,
YOU NEED THE SECOND SPECIAL
COUNSEL LIKE YESTERDAY.
IT ALL THE NEEDS TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
PEOPLE NEED TO BE EXPOSED.
CRIMES WERE COMMITTED AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS, AND PEOPLE
IN THE END NEED TO GO TO
JAIL.
THE FULL STORY NEEDS TO COME
OUT.
YOU DESERVE THAT AND SO MUCH
MORE FROM THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE SUPPOSED TO SERVE YOU IN
GOVERNMENT.
ALL RIGHT.
ALSO TONIGHT, WE HAVE
BREAKING NEWS ON PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND RUSSIA.
NOW, IT DOESN'T EXACTLY FIT
IN THE NARRATIVE THAT
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEMBERS OF
THE DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA HAVE
BEEN PUSHING FOR MONTHS.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ARE
CRACKING DOWN ON RUSSIA IN A
MASSIVE WAY.
NOW, THIS MORNING, THE
TREASURY DEPARTMENT
ANNOUNCED NEW TARGETED
SANCTIONS AGAINST DOZENS OF
RUSSIAN ENTITIES AND
INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED IN
CYBER ATTACKS AND ELECTION
INTERFERENCE IN THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
AND THAT'S NOT ALL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE IS
JOINING LEADERS FROM GERMANY
AND FRANCE AND THE UNITED
KINGDOM IN A JOINT STATEMENT
CONDEMNING THE PUTIN REGIME
FOR BRUTALLY POISONING A
FORMER DOUBLE AGENT AND HIS
DAUGHTER LAST WEEK IN
ENGLAND.
NOW, THE PAIR REMAIN ALIVE
BUT THEY ARE IN CRITICAL
CONDITION IN A BRITISH
HOSPITAL.
NOW, THIS ALL COMES MONTHS
AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP
INTRODUCED HIS
ADMINISTRATION'S FIRST
SANCTIONS AGAINST RUSSIA,
MEANT TO PUNISH THE PUTIN
REGIME FOR ITS ACTIONS IN
CRIMEA.
WELL, THAT HAPPENED DURING
THE OBAMA YEARS AS WELL AS
OTHER HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS.
NOW, OF COURSE, THIS TOUGH
POLICY, IT DOES STAND IN
STARK CONTRAST TO WHAT
HAPPENED UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
AND WHEN HILLARY WAS
SECRETARY OF STATE.
REMEMBER, THAT LAME RUSSIAN
RESET BUTTON THAT SHE HANDED
OVER TO HER COUNTERPART.
AND CONTINUING WITH OBAMA'S
TOTAL INACTION DURING
RUSSIA'S HOSTILE TAKEOVER OF
CRIMIA, DESPITE WARNINGS
FROM WORLD LEADERS, OUR OWN
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY AND EVEN
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES,
REMEMBER, DEVIN NUNES WROTE
THIS OP-ED WARNING THEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA ABOUT THE
KREMLIN'S HOSTILE ACTIONS IN
EASTERN EUROPE.
AND ELECTIONS.
AND WARNED SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT THE 2016 ELECTIONS.
AND THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THEY ALSO
DROPPED THE BALL IN THE
MIDDLE EAST WHEN RUSSIA
BOOSTED THE ASSAD REGIME IN
THE FIGHT AGAINST SYRIAN
REBELS.
REMEMBER THE RED LINE?
ASSAD CROSSED IT AND NOTHING
HAPPENED.
HE GASSED HIS OWN PEOPLE.
RUSSIA SUPPORTED IT OBAMA
STOOD BY AND DID NOTHING.
AND THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
WASN'T ANY BETTER ON RUSSIAN
ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
ACCORDING TO EXPERTS, BRAND
NEW BOOK MICHAEL ISIKOFF.
FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR SUSAN RICE.
HE ISSUES A QUOTE.
A STAND DOWN ORDER TO
OFFICIALS DEVELOPING AN
AGGRESSIVE RESPONSE TO
PUTIN'S MEDDLING.
NOW, REMEMBER, WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA TOLD THEN
CANDIDATE TRUMP, DO YOU
REMEMBER THIS?
STOP WHINING.
YOU KNOW, NO SERIOUS PERSON
THINKS THAT OUR ELECTIONS
COULD EVER BE INFLUENCED BY
HACKING, COME ON, STOP BEING
A WHINER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE IS NO SERIOUS
PERSON OUT THERE WHO WOULD
SUGGEST SOMEHOW THAT YOU
COULD EVEN -- YOU COULD EVEN
RIG AMERICA'S ELECTIONS.
IN PART BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
DECENTRALIZED, AND THE
NUMBERS OF VOTES INVOLVED.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT
THAT HAS HAPPENED IN THE
PAST OR THAT THERE ARE
INSTANCES IN WHICH THAT WILL
HAPPEN THIS TIME.
AND SO, I WOULD ADVISE
MR. TRUMP TO STOP WHINING
AND GO TRY TO MAKE HIS CASE
TO GET VOTES.
>> Sean: LET'S GET THIS
STRAIGHT.
THERE'S OBAMA WEAK ON
RUSSIAN'S HOSTILE TAKE
OVERCRIMEA.
WEAK ON RUSSIA USING GAS ON
OWN PEEK.
WEAK ON RUSSIA'S HACKING
WARNED TWO YEARS BEFORE THE
2016 ELECTION, AND THE MEDIA
IS ONLY FOCUSED ON TRUMP'S
TIES TO RUSSIA?
MR. OBAMA, WHERE WERE YOU?
WHY DIDN'T YOU ACT?
I SAID IT BEFORE, I'LL SAY
IT AGAIN, JOURNALISM IN THIS
COUNTRY IS DEAD.
IT DOESN'T EXIST.
WE BREAK MORE NEWS HERE THAN
ALL THESE SO-CALLED NEWS
PEOPLE PUT TOGETHER.
ALSO BREAKING TONIGHT,
SPEAKING OF THE FAKE NEWS
MEDIA, THEY ARE HARD AT
WORK, DESPERATELY TRYING TO
STOP STORIES ABOUT REAL
DEMOCRATIC SCANDALS, THE
ONES WE'RE REPORTING,
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO BOOMER
RANG BACK ON THEM.
FOR OVER A YEAR, THE
DECEITFUL FAKE NEWS MEDIA IN
THIS COUNTRY HAS BEEN FLAT
OUT LYING TO YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, DAY BY DAY,
HOUR BY HOUR.
AND NOW THE BIASED PRESS,
THEY ARE EMPLOYING A BRAND
NEW TACTIC.
PAY ATTENTION.
SPREAD COMPLETELY FALSE
INFORMATION.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" IS
CLAIMING TO HAVE A
BLOCKBUSTER STORY ABOUT
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER ISSUING A SUBPOENA
TO THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION TO
TURN OVER DOCUMENTS.
OKAY.
THIS PARTICULAR STORY IS A
DEFINITION OF FAKE NEWS.
IT'S A SMEAR TO DAMAGE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
HERE ASK WHY.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS STARGETS
EARLIER TODAY, TRUMP
ORGANIZATION SINCE JULY OF
2017 WE HAVE ADVISED THE
PUBLIC THAT THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION IS FULLY
COOPERATIVE WITH ALL
INVESTIGATIONS, INCLUDING
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL, AND ARE
RESPONDING TO ALL THEIR
REQUESTS.
THIS IS OLD NEWS AND OUR
ASSISTANCE AND COOPERATION
WITH THE VARIOUS
INVESTIGATIONS REMAINS THE
SAME TODAY.
OH, OLD NEWS, RECYCLED BY
PATHETIC LIBERAL LAP DOG
MEDIA SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS.
THEY HAVE WASTED 14 MONTHS
BEATING THE DRUM NIGHT AFTER
NIGHT, NIGHT AFTER NIGHT,
DAY AFTER DAY, HOUR AFTER
HOUR ABOUT A CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
NONE EXISTS.
NO EVIDENCE EXISTS.
IT'S BEEN A BIG LIE.
AND THE MEDIA HAS
DELIBERATELY SPREAD FALSE
INFORMATION AND PROPAGANDA
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT PUTIN
AND THE RUSSIANS WANT.
ISN'T THAT WHAT THEY WANTED
TO DO SOW DISIN ORDER
AMERICA.
ALL SEEMS TO DO SLAMMING
TRUMP AND DELET JIT SIZING
TRUMP AND DE AT JIT SIZING
TRUMP AND DE ANDJIT SIZING
TRUMP AND DE AND -T SIZING
TRUMP AND DE AND -- SIZING
TRUMP AND DE AND -- DIZING
TRUMP AND DE AND -- DRAING
TRUMP AND DE AND -- DRAWNG
TRUMP AND DE AND -- DRAW ATTENTI
TRUMP AND DE AND -- DRAW ATTENTN
FROM THE MASSIVE DEMOCRATIC
SCANDALS AND NOT LET ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE MEDIA FOCUS ON
ANYTHING THAT HAS REAL
EVIDENCE INCONTROVERTIBLE.
REAL FACT, REAL EVIDENCE.
AS FOR ROBERT MUELLER'S
SPECIAL COUNSEL THIS LATEST
LEAK IS NOT SURPRISING.
WHAT HE IS DOING IS
DELIBERATE.
TEAM OF DEMOCRATIC DONORS,
HILLARY DONORS, OBAMA
DONORS, DNC DONORS, THEY ARE
SELECTIVELY LEAKING DAILY TO
THE MEDIA TO KEEP PRESIDENT
TRUMP OFF BALANCE.
MUELLER DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
THE TRUTH OR EVIDENCE OR
FACTS.
BECAUSE HE IS BENT ON A
WITCH-HUNT.
LOOK AT THE TEAM HE HAS PUT
TOGETHER.
THE LEAKS ARE OBVIOUSLY
INTENTIONAL BECAUSE IT
HAPPENS EVERY DAY.
IF MUELLER REALLY CARED
ABOUT UNCOVERING REAL
CRIMES, REAL WRONGDOING,
MUELLER, YOU WOULD BE
INVESTIGATING THEM.
YOU KNOW, IF MUELLER IS
GOING TO KEEP EXPANDING HIS
MANDATE, WHY DOESN'T HE
FOCUS ON THE CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN DOSSIER
WITH RUSSIAN LIES?
DOES MUELLER NOT CARE THAT
HILLARY PAID FOR THIS
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA AND SHE
DID IT TO INFLUENCE AN
ELECTION?
DOES MUELLER NOT CARE THAT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE IS AN
UNREGISTERED FOREIGN AGENT
WHO HATES PRESIDENT TRUMP?
DOES MUELLER NOT CARE ABOUT
THE FBI LYING TO A FISA
JUDGE NOT ONCE, TWICE, THREE
TIMES, BUT FOUR TIMES?
USING AN UNVERIFIED DOSSIER
AS THE BULK OF THE
APPLICATION TO GET A WARRANT
FROM FISA JUDGES TO SPY ON A
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE SO THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO EVERYTHING IN
THAT CAMPAIGN?
DOES MUELLER NOT CARE THAT
THIS FISA WARRANT LIKELY
GAVE ACCESS TO ALL OF TRUMP
CAMPAIGN'S COMMUNICATIONS
DURING ELECTIONS?
I CAN GO ON ALL NIGHT.
DOES ROBERT MUELLER, SIR, DO
YOU REALLY NOT CARE THAT
CLINTON FIXED AND HAD FIXED
FOR HER THAT EMAIL
INVESTIGATION AND WE KNOW
CRIMES WERE COMMITTED OR THE
UNMASKING SCANDAL OF 350%
INCREASE IN ONE YEAR?
OR THE URANIUM ONE SCANDAL?
YOU WERE THE FBI DIRECTOR AT
THE TIME.
WE HAD AN FBI INFORMANT THAT
INFILTRATED PUTIN'S CRIMINAL
SCHEME TO CONTROL AMERICA'S
URANIUM.
WELL, HAVE YOU NO PROBLEM
GOING DOWN EVERY OTHER
RABBIT HOLE, MR. MUELLER,
WHY DON'T YOU LOOK INTO
THESE SCANDALS?
THIS IS WHY WE NEED THE
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL.
SOMEONE THAT IS GOING TO
LEAD FROM THE OUTSIDE THE
SWAMP.
YOU CAN'T HAVE PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THESE SCANDALS
INVESTIGATING THEMSELVES.
THAT MEANS MUELLER.
THAT MEANS COMEY.
ALL -- FRIENDSHIPS GOING ON
HERE, ROD ROSENSTEIN, THEY
ARE ALL BFF, OLD COLLEAGUES.
YOU REALLY THINK THEY'RE
GOING TO HOLD THEMSELVES AND
EACH OTHER ACCOUNTABLE?
OF COURSE ATTORNEY GENERAL
JEFF SESSIONS, HE CREATED
THIS SPECIAL COUNSEL
WITCH-HUNT, NOW HE NEEDS TO
FIX IT YOU CAN'T BE
CONFIRMED THE A.G. AND THEN
THE NEXT DAY RECUSE YOURSELF
AND BY THE WAY SITE
AND BY THE WAY CITE THE LONG
LAW AS GREGG JARRETT POINTED
OUT LAST NIGHT.
WE NEED THE SECOND SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR.
JEFF SESSIONS KNEW HE WAS
GOING TO RECUSE HIMSELF.
HE NEVER SHOULD HAVE
ACCEPTED THE JOB AS ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
LOOK AT THE CHAOS THAT AS A
RESULT OF ALL OF THIS.
HERE'S A KEY FACT.
GREGG JARRETT POINTED THIS
OUT.
SESSIONS CITED THE WRONG LAW
AS THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
RECUSING HIMSELF.
HE SHUT ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SO, THE BURDENNIBLE OF ALL
OF THIS, IS DRAGGING THIS
COUNTRY DOWN, FALLS SQUARELY
ON JEFF SESSIONS' SOLDIERS.
TONIGHT, MR. ATTORNEY
GENERAL, DO YOUR JOB AND FIX
THE MESS YOU CREATED.
AND ALSO TONIGHT, ANOTHER
DAMNING REPORT ABOUT JAMES
COMEY'S INCOMPETENCE AND HIS
HIGHLY QUESTIONABLE CONDUCT
WHILE LEADING THE FBI.
FRIEND JOHN SOLOMON
REPORTING THAT THE LONG TIME
HEAD OF THE FBI
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SURVEILLANCE UNIT IS SAYING
THAT HE WARNED JAMES COMEY
ABOUT HOW THAT PARTICULAR
SPY PROGRAM WAS DANGEROUSLY
INEFFECTIVE IN CATCHING
TERRORISTS.
COMEY NEVER TRIED TO FIX IT
THAT'S LIKE OBAMA WAS WARNED
ABOUT RUSSIAN COLLUSION AND
INFLUENCING OUR ELECTIONS
AND DID NOTHING AND LAUGHED
AT THE IDEA.
HERE IS WHAT THE RETIRED
SPECIAL AGENT TOLD JOHN
SOLOMON.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I BELIEVE THAT THE
PROGRAM AS IT WAS WAS RIPE
FOR POTENTIAL ABUSES.
REGARDLESS OF HOW IT'S
ABUSED BUT IT COULD BE.
AND FRANKLY, I SEE WHAT'S
BEEN HAPPENING IN THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF.
AND THAT JUST PROVES THE
POINT THAT THIS PROGRAM
COULD BE ABUSED AND THAT IT